a lot of colorful language on the show
that your character uses what's a roster
Bader Oh a roster Bader is someone who
thinks that their roster is so good they
can get off on it okay what's vinegar
strokes I have no idea what that what
that term means no that's too bad
vinegars to vinegar strokes is the face
that one makes when orgasming and the
term came about in a scene with Nick
Kroll yeah you know yeah and the phrase
a guy Nick Kroll yes he's humorous the
face he makes when orgasming
looks like he's chugging vinegar it's
like a kind of like horrible
I'm sorry any woman has to see that face
but apparently that's what he looks like
that's okay I don't know why he's
telling you what he looks like you're
paranoid how he knows yeah how does he
know yeah there's some Arietta mirrors
in the
[Applause]
in my show I am very comfortable you
were that close to bass I can so much
it's just it's a little dispenser of
whoop-ass your parents some time that
you find your parents like what do they
like because the show can get as graphic
there can be some bold language how do
your parents feel about that you know
they're very proud they're proud very
proud I come from a very small town on
the coast of Maine of 300 people where
my dad is the town doctor and my mom is
the president of the Garden Club and I
do what I do I talk about vaginal hubris
and vinegar strokes
what's vaginal hubris that is exactly
what you think it might be it's someone
who I have no idea
I have a lot of confidence in their
hoo-ha well you mean like to do stunts
and stuff no I think my character is
watch what my vagina he's behaving
himself Mike's behavior sorry my
character has a lot of confidence in her
yes and she is a dump
it's a double standard here you said who
are the first time why don't you like
and i said vagina and then you've got to
go you've got a go I'm not my character
I said it I think I would like to say
for the very first time on basic cable
on maybe season two and it was shocking
for me I think it was the first time I
ever said it out loud but now I just say
it all yeah well now